this is uh going to be our last session
of the day and of the week it is my a
great pleasure to introduce you new uh
yeah uh professor at Stanford
um where to begin on on introducing you
so you can use done really foundational
work across all of optimization Theory
written a book on a non-linear and
linear optimization been one of the
pioneers of interior Point methods more
awards that I that I uh can count let's
look at something on your website about
like 55 000 citations for papers or
something like this
um and it's really my pleasure to
introduce you for this talk at the end
you know all week we've talked at
various points about certain algorithmic
breakthroughs and advances that in some
way shape or form used interior Point
methods or related to something about
interior Point methods but we haven't
really gone into depth on interior Point
methods and that is the last thing we
will be doing for this boot camp week
you can use one of the pioneers of this
subject and I am delighted to hear your
talk look at the subject thank you good
thank you for for Aaron my colleague and
in adoption uh I I'm going to I couldn't
see all the young people and also all
the friends
so uh Aaron asked me to give a very very
Elementary like a basic concept
introduction of the so-called in
two-point arguments
uh so what I'm gonna do is the first
part I'm going to focus on some basic
you know Concept in key Point algorithms
maybe some perspective how to looking at
the you know in two point arguments then
second bar part is going to be a little
bit more advanced and on the coverage of
the central pass so for overall
objective still one focus on linear
programming and the weather we can
really get the so-called strongly
polynomial time algorithms okay to me
that's the you know central question
it's not you know Nina program is still
remaining a very very open field for
everybody jumping and try to lock that
question down wherever okay
so uh I'm going to go slowly and this is
a boot camp okay uh so uh no this is uh
this is a I I borrowed this slide from
the you know uh Daniel
and also Bento Bento supposed to be also
here and we uh so he this slides
basically you know what's the linear
program is about okay so Nina
programming is still try to finding a
polyhedral and the constraints put it
all I mean 2D and you try to find the
optimal solution uh you know has been
the focus of the whole optimization how
to develop the efficient arguments then
we have a Simplex math method we have
some now so recently have some circuit
work algorithms and of course the
central path and then in 2.0 program
follow this Central path there was some
other just like ad hoc and like a black
box
algorithms so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to focus on this ipn interior
Point algorithms okay so uh I thought
here's the linear programming I'm going
to on in this basic form
I might be choosing eggs which is the
vector and minimize the linear objective
functions subject to constraints I'm
writing this abstract a x equal to B4 X
has to be non-active component wise when
I say X 10
that's our problems okay a basic concept
uh interpreter algorithm is defined with
the interior of this feasible region
okay so the phase of origin is defined
by
and so-called interior is by component
wise each one is strictly positive okay
region have such a strictly positive
feasible solution satisfy those
equations okay same thing for the two
problems
so everybody understands what's that do
do is have this snack variables have
these y variables we have to be creating
the zero who assume this is not
also not empty either okay so uh with
these conditions well we know of course
even any Facebook LP we use the Z Star
you know the optimal value we basically
want to finding a solution such that The
Duality Gap is less than Epsilon okay so
for Simplicity where some will have
interior point of power which is start
with so we have a solution x0 strict
positive satisfying equations we also
have a y zero satisfied snack variable
also strictly positive okay
so interior product attributed to kamaka
okay of course religa I'm just uh
who has done fundamental work on this
area
[Music]
okay so a p associate with this linear
programming
is defined as a so-called logarithmic
barrier functions okay so in that Primal
feasible region we want for funding a
sum of log X G which is the maximized
but usually we take a look
about yeah so we minimize with Photon
active same scene we put the do we add
log functions
okay so this is called the logarithmic
Berry so this problem itself assume this
Facebook reading spank it has in theory
that you also boundaries in theory then
the minimizer or the maximize for this
always exists okay so this is a
so-called minion constraint the convex
programs
this problem actually start much much
early because this is a so-called
barrier functions if you want to prevent
X goes to zero you want to maximize them
okay
okay so this is what now okay
this the maximizer for this problem
because this strong convex is strong
convex problem for doing strong concave
functions so the minimizer is a unique
so this unique minimizer will be given
name is called the analytical Center
okay
uh there was many many different ways to
find a center in a polytope correct okay
so if you give any any Polito if you you
if you have some prototype which is
defined okay let's let's say
this pen work okay so yeah you can you
can Define analytical scientific then
because for example center of gravity
that's a sentence okay you can Define
like a lot of like a center minimize
mean of the distance to each particle
that's also a center
somehow uh
the center gravity is very hard to
compute
even burning is hard
so some other scent some others for
example minimize most distance sometimes
sometimes not unique but some other
lotion but analytical this logarithmic
Battery Center
is also uh very nice okay so you can
also think about these two problems
actually also a primer and new programs
so modernistic barrier function have
this self-due property
Finance for example you'll find what's
the deal of this problem it becomes
useful
so so it's across the unique we call the
underground Center and this can be
written for example the analytics Center
for these Primal problems you can write
up this into this automatic conditions
okay you can write this x equal to e and
this is the vector of all ones okay so
uh it's just a satisfied Primal phase
region this is a do of course the due
become a homogeneous and you can do so
give the name to this problem this code
is go back to 88 Sun event and Bayern
nagaris and also mekido also you know
modernize the property of this anal
consultant okay
so uh this also got the two-phase bridge
you see this Center all gives the same
condition if you go to reduce feasible
solution and you know basically it's a
theory is maximize this one right
what's this this is all snack variables
right what's the snap snap variable
represented in the due prototype is the
distance to each of these constraints
okay so uh you you maximize the sum of
log that's the same and maximize the
product
okay so you can see once you maximize
product each of these snack variables
value you don't want this to be on the
boundary whatever
okay
so so that's the another consent that's
the geometric Phantom
okay there was also other centers and
you can maximize some deterministic goes
to valsia and built on that one you know
around you know many other people also
did a wonderful work okay but somehow uh
this analytical volume still for this
Simplicity still played very very
important role okay so these ones
dependent so why we call the analytical
Center
that's because this Center is not
invariant
uh with the representation of the
political
for example
you just consider this feasible region
it's an interval one-dimensional why
greater zero another y greatness equal
to one let's represent the interval in
one key ministers zero to one the you
know the another if you just replace
this one a little something just a half
right in the middle you know
but however if we repeat this constraint
like end times would happen
you still same intervals but in Center
shift
okay so that's why we call this as
analytical sound it's really function of
a and a c whatever
is not
invariant in terms of geometry so it
really depends on representation
you may think this is the bad thing but
this can be also good thing because it's
the analytical you can you know do a lot
of things analyze what's the well
very smooth very continuous and just
the stuff okay so later on I'm going to
show me show you something okay so
that's why we call it this is analytical
it's really yeah it usually represents
this same kind of
geometry subject object but it's that
different the A and A C and then the
center shift
okay so that's why somehow linear
programming is also very hard especially
when you want to establish a lower bound
then it basically people add some crazy
quality constraint to make it very hard
to solve because any any linear program
you solve they can only recognize a and
C they cannot see what's going on in the
real shape of the feasible region
whatever
so okay
so with this political Center
we also defined what's the volume you
know I know
typical volume
in the common sense you have a warning
but the size of the political feasible
region right for example the intervals
just nine c is equal to one however
because the representation differently
you can also decide Define what's the
analytical value okay what is the
analytical Finance it's basically for
any point
it's just this product those maximizer
the the product of those snack variables
snack values you can Define as an
electrical volume so analytical Center
that also because the you maximize and
the product of those things you can you
can use that matches the size of the
body top
okay
so that's the whole idea which is people
call and you know this is called the
potential functions it's called the
analytical variance Okay so
what's the probability you know to me
most algorithms
uh if you want to get some kind of a
polynomial Improvement like a universoid
what do you do you cut something you
know in episode
contain optimal solution it's always
shrinking here
that's how you develop some kind of
convergence since
okay so all you can you can do all the
things but not that's in two point also
have this kind of geometrical
interpretation it's meaning is really
reduce some kind of Havana the turnout
it is it is reduced analytical volume of
a polypobe contains the optimal solution
okay so in some sense for example what's
the property and let me just give you
this picture suppose we have one two
three four five inequalities okay
uh We've resigned by some linear
inequality we have defined a center
okay
now suppose one of the hyperplane
replaced
cut through the current Atlantic Center
how much analytic converter of this new
small political
compared to the other one
okay
that makes sense
you can think about this so one of your
objective hyperplane right it was
originally placed over here now I really
want to minimize this then I placed over
here I completed the new new medical
center then I move this again because
this sequential cut through this another
percentage right
method or something whatever
not questions
when all the political is getting
smaller and smooth
but the two successive warrants
decreased by how much
okay so this is the geometric
interpretation okay so basically very
easy I replaced let's say we have this
we defined this let's say C1 is replaced
C1 move to C1 C1 plus C1 plus actually
equal to this racism is unchanged
it's defined is showing more than half
this e to the negative one
okay
the proof is very simple very inventory
just write down the optimal condition
for the two successive representation of
the politov they use this electrical
properties
okay uh actually if you want to take a
look uh that yeah it's just just a per
page yeah you just use this minus one
thomasment this is n is the number for
those inequalities
very Elementary
okay
so this immediately give you occurrence
like a little concerned cutting plane
method you keep translating your
objective hyperplane you know and
downward
you go to optimality of course the
issues sometimes this actually
eventually is the is the is the
renegence algorithms so when you when
you move this objective 5 and downward
you don't move until you cut through
Center you give some room the current
Center still in the interior of the new
Facebook region I'm only cut half away
okay because the e to the minus one I
don't need to be that aggressive then
you can compute the new and then consent
from the other center with the other
Center still in the interior of the new
political one Beauty step you will do it
okay
so that's the different the geometrical
interpretation rather than just in terms
of objective value how much getting
closer it's just underneath this one is
because of why
because this volume maybe also give you
a new perspective
now suppose okay so here's the proof
suppose I now I go back to this pictures
this is the something in the beside
method very hard to do
how about I translate two cups through
hyperplane
I will understand what I mean okay
not only this objectively the hyperplane
transport I also need to Value this one
so you have one cholesterol over there
and another one color over here okay now
I give the picture which is looks like
this so this one also needs to
translated over there so it's like this
this new product after two hyperplane
translated even become smaller right
and ask the same question how much one
has decreased from the old one but
translates two cards
in episode method is very hard to do
actually people want to do enough so it
okay and uh it's very hard to find this
most value and contain half its so it is
it's very hard to to contain a sector
because once you conveying the two type
of plants becomes very hard
what's the answer
is Generation to an active key
okay
there's a number of hyperplane you're
translated
of course
if I have too many high frame translated
then your
your your Steel Center can be hard to
compute so you don't want to translate
too much whatever
so this property
actually
so the one application of this probably
is
well if I only have one objective I need
to translate this
only translate why in episode in one
card only gives me reduction
into the negative one right
how should I take advantage of this
property is proportional to number of
cards you translated
what do you do
if this is your objective hyperplane
your capitalism clear times
remember
I still represent our general have more
weight instead so this is my objective
hyperplane
something less than something
I repeat them time traveling three times
politova does not change
but
because at duplicate times I translated
one of them and translate care of them
get more reduction
that's the idea
and if you go back of course generally
not from this objective hyphen is a
weighted square root of n times
that's how you get a reduction square
root and Improvement
y square one right now the N times once
you're trying to Too Much the new center
can be harder to compute okay
so you push them too far
so this is a weight
interpretation and how to do this other
question yes
duplicate the objective yes rather than
the analytical volume also go up because
yes so you have to go back to just uh
you know logarithmic is just two and
whatever you know so if you already
operate x square the N is M plus
whatever and but you'd reduce the value
dramatically
that's right you know what's the balance
over there maybe one more question yeah
how this you're going to view into your
point of path following as this
translation later on yes yes this is
eventually it is a translation Yes
actually yeah okay yeah this no this is
say this this is the past following
algorithms this is it's just if you if
you think about it you continue to
translate those hyperplane this is
the so-called Central plus that's the
geometric interpretations of course you
can parameterize the by different the
parameter in terms of Duality Gap
so why is this the first time many of us
are hearing this yeah
why this is the title part could you oh
Okay so
suppose you only translate this infinite
small amount
so another Santa will shift correct
continuous push these hyper Prince
gradually
this River Center also gradually moves
right
but why is this the same as this
oh yes so later on you can write
you can formulate by any any things you
can write with the judge algebraic curve
for this this path then you prove that
Central pulse is the same as the MU
primary thread by mu whatever
yeah basically informing this kind of
invariant like like a one-on-one
correspondence
so
so this is uh what you can you can all
I'm trying to say is it's very easy
that's the advantage the analytical
things we can even do very deep okay so
you can do multiple cards
okay so now you have it you can send the
cutting plane method and then you can
actually reduce this well of course in
we did not translate well every this
kind of things is going to be become
instant like a differential equation we
fixed discrete equations right you
translate by something it's become a
piecewise Millennial
path or whatever so yeah so yeah I'm
gonna yeah you can prove this is exactly
the essential password
so what's the application
suppose you have a much more objective
I really want the founding operator
optimal solution for multiple objectives
what do you do
so this image no one way to do this or
you can wait a different objectives
right none of them all move you know in
some fashion for example yeah I really
want suppose I have
I'm just say suppose my face were
reaching like this
I really find I really want to maximize
your objective on this direction I also
want to maximize the objective on that
direction
so from here I'm moving it from here I
move it
if you just waited
many people dealing with much objective
by the ways with many many in in
economics you really have much more
objective read one of the spiritual so
if you do something like this it's just
a weighted decisions
maybe the solution will be become these
Solutions
because anything from the weight will
move you to the one of the color
solution
but if you think about this you can use
this electrical card
first and move this objectively
understand and then move this little bit
to adjust ultimately move it
it will give you a solution what
is always in the middle of this line
so many people think about this solution
although in terms of you know if you
just simply like average it into a one
weighted extensions the solution may
give you some Color Solutions okay
even you waited by exact half maybe
still give you the polar solution
because the whole because the whole
phase becomes the optimal solution that
awaited some objective
but in terms these two objective
people usually think what's the fair
solution
where's the fair operator not not only
want to pray to Optimal you know pray to
obvious so you can improve one without
the suffering rather right
well any color solution over here is the
Pareto but which one is the fair
you can use this alternating cutting
objective or simultaneous move them you
know
then that will give you a solution in
the middle
and also you convergence very fast
because
yeah but of course you say knitting
program I only have a single objective
what I do I just duplicate it yes
is there a way to use this to identify
that that entire facet
oh that's a good question
yeah I think that depends on your
sequence of how to how to move each
objective maybe if you can I don't know
it may be always they always give you
one sandwich to one solution if you fix
the order of those translations
if it always affects them they only
converge to one point
but different different orders
differences maybe give you need to point
so there's no one
canonical
there was no I
think this can be identified the entire
optimal solution facet yeah and then
yeah that's a good question for them but
probably we still need to but but but
maybe weka identifies the optimal facet
from linear programming so later on I'm
going to talk about maybe another
related so we cannot finding all the
possible Color Solutions all the you
know but we can find them what's the
what's the what's the definition of the
optimal FaceTime
yeah I I don't I don't I don't know
exact answer to another question that's
yeah but anyway so this is uh you can
you can you know alternativity or follow
different orders or some attention with
the fixed proportions or something
because you cut through always you know
same move in the same same speed they
will convert to one two according to
water speed what's the proportion the
speed when you cut
but anyway this is actually this is what
the one your computer
like a facial Market you know which is
the weighted Energy Center what you do
is just you calculate this methods
equilibrium point
not the central path okay so uh this is
so what I Scout you you duplicate the K
times you can follow this but it's
really that yeah so this gives you a
medical center just push you can think
about this the push and then you can
Define this nautical Center and but
however
as I said very good a better
recognization is
very functions
are the exactly the same way
okay so approve that successive Center
cutting plane by inflate influence more
movement which move the center consent
but that's the same thing as Panini
programming you add a barrier function
which I talked about before
the primary tries by mu same thing to
the two
you and is also this should be as this
is yeah this is in the two-phase region
same thing in the Primal phase version
uses
okay
it turned out
do you have this problem if you write it
was all different
bench whatever French duo or something
it provides the two of these problems
this dual exist for mistakes
so log function
have this self-duality party
so some of the you know for some other
organizations
they know better function is not unique
better functioning is any function if
you approach the boundary that goes to
Infinity right
for example 1 over s is also a battery
function
but one over s that battery function is
not self do
actually if you read that problem would
have rather that does not give you a
better function for the first for this
problem
so as so that maybe when you're teaching
students she didn't ask why you have to
use logarithmic to do a barrel function
my answer is it I have very good
self-due Duality positive
originally the program primer do after
battery the steel primer do
yes
what will be the Duel of one of us Jade
oh uh actually I don't remember is to
become a square root of something
and it's yeah some something is like a
polynomial or some polynomial yeah you
can write very explicitly because
yes where will this Duality show up like
will be able to see this why this
Duality is important oh yes so you
this become an amino organization
problem right with some linear
constraints what you do is you always
form the LaGrange functions
then you you write that optimal
connection with an economic functions
then you can construct the Dual problem
yeah so because this is log it becomes a
due it becomes longer again whatever
why is this why why is it important that
what I love like why why will it be
useful oh so uh first it has a log I
have this Duality functions as it is the
self do so I minimize one of them is
actually it's the same minimize the and
the other one with with with this
parameterization with the due okay so it
is like now you can use a prime module
and then later on you can find the log s
also have very good you know and Alpha
Concord and the battery function have
some property Newton method especially
good yeah so when you're working on some
optimization problem if if that were
privilege is self do they usually give
some advantages to control it
okay so you you it's like you
automatically what one of them you work
for another one they all aimed at the
same kind of for you it should help each
other
with all the self do sometimes is
very hard
okay yes
or for better function this is the only
one only for for non-active author
of course you may have a stiffness for
example semi definitely programming
determinant of Matrix
that you were gonna do they also it's
like the same thing it's like a dual
edit those kind of thing yeah so yeah
this you have more better function but
depending on different
for this non-active cones this log
function
according to mainologies only as smoke s
itself do
okay
you can write down the explicit of what
it looks like
so
so this uh so for example one advantage
is
because they are self-due you write
obtuse your white optimal condition for
this one that optimal condition is the
same for this one
okay so that's the one of the working
self-due property whatever okay so you
have a one characterization
characterized with the central part all
primary Choice basis mu so what is this
XS so this is basically a point where
this is basically x g times SG equal to
Mu for all the year so I I you know I
usually students in my class they need
they like Matrix representation so this
big X is like a diagonal of those X
vectors
so this times this just a component-wise
product they're all equal to the same
meal it turned out
once you satisfy these conditions X
for any given View
x x is the minimized for this Y is the
maximized for this you see because they
sell to level so you you solve one of
them
you get the other one as a byproduct
so
because again is the unities so you can
think about this solution
you can write down these ones so this so
this is what you can do here as long as
this they are satisfy this you can prove
your necklace and everything since then
you comparise the bamboo as the for any
given meal so you you take a derivative
with Vector mu and everything you can do
all the all the crazy things but anyway
and X review value as Mu
constitute a path one dimensional path
why is the Primal feasible region
another one is the geophysical region
they come one to one okay always have a
pair associated with same meal not
parameter
you can prove that's the same as your
transmitter they are rep they are a
medical center associated with some
objective card
so this is uh so this is so-called yeah
you can also do this
uh I don't know if there was many many
properties
Okay so
this is also I really want to emphasize
of course if the as Mu goes to zero and
this part of this maximizer or minimize
converge to a solution okay Optimus
rules
sometimes
if your optimal solution set
if your optimal solution is unique what
is a converges
the process still converges
because it starts a break
cool
the Indian at a single point
s always converge to in this case
suppose you need a program or objective
hyperplane exact Parable for this
okay
this part converts it to a point
in the optimal screen set
another point is a medical center with
all these ones to be tight but it's
still including all other inequality as
constraints with defined analytical
Center of that optimal solution phase
Sun becomes zero okay some snack
variable becomes zero
you fix them equal to zero
you still consider all other
inequalities
always converge to Interior point
but all only the interior point is still
remaining another consent in that facet
so if from a higher dimensional facet
America converted to a no dimensional
fats
the center
so there were companies to this point
actually we'll be able
to identify those facet
okay
so I just say this probably become very
very important
because especially in the in in the
presence of some kind of like a like a
you know which point if this if this
entire line segment is optimal solution
so in terms of economic revenue or some
profit
doesn't matter which point
okay you use you give the same line
objective
again people ask
if optimal solution
in terms this priority objective is
multiple
now which point
would it be better
it is the is this can you still rank
those Solutions one way or another you
know in terms of objective function does
make a difference
okay and it's the most recent work is on
again coming on the families which which
is the fair Optimal Solutions
okay
many people think and fails fail
solution should be some kind of average
of all the optimal solution correct
is one of those
not only that
so this has become an issue in the old
days we think
into your point map solution does not
give you a caller solution
it may be a bad things
now you can think about maybe this is a
good thing because they give you a fair
Solutions the average all the Optimal
Solutions
okay because inside if this would be a
resource allocation color solution may
be biased against the other group or
whatever
another Advantage is
in many many especially on nine million
programming what is the online
programming
here we decide what's the value for X1
to X and all together with until
information I mean some
some situation
the solution together with the
associated information comes
sequentially you have to decide one
immediately those Point information
arrives you cannot wait until completely
ABC are constructed
this is the typical many many mentioned
learning program has this kind of sort
of online learning or online mini
programming
one of the assumptions and most of the
algorithms they're basically you want to
condense the shutter price
but if shorter price is not unique what
do you use
to me you know why my developed and
learning and generalization Bank those
kind of things you always assume the
ones since you want to condemn the
target is unique
how do you
developer algorithm to learn faster
then you can use that under consent
because it's still unique still optimal
so you have a fixed Target okay
so this is the summer applications okay
so yeah the proof actually is not it's
also very Elementary so this part is the
Builder and so is the math here is the
mathematician
so anyway you can you can you can this
past following parameter Tried by this
view so each time we can create reduce
mu now you solve that this is called the
primer Duo uh yeah
the algorithms okay anyway so you can
reduce mu by this square root n this is
the equivalent duplicate objective by
square root n times and at the same time
you can complete a new center
one newton step so that's the trade-off
so uh this is all the reason I of course
Jim Marine guns are going to origin is
the Dual based the only updated they do
but somehow because the self-duality you
only work on the view is equivalent is
still working on the primer uh there was
a uh so what the most popular one I I
know probably most people here don't
care what's the you know practical
computation efficiency but in practice
people use the primer do we do the
method so basically update the primary
and do simultaneously
so they basically get that single
optimal condition
is some kind of food you know many
equations you just apply building to it
working on both Prime module Okay so
that's that's the way that's the most
okay
yes one more time to say why this square
root n appears yeah so square root and
appeals is because so so the algorithm
is basically they Define some
neighborhood nobody is going to complete
the exactly Learning Center for not even
mu
okay so for example what's the given
meal what is the exact clinical Center
another consent is x i k x g h i k equal
to new case right
but however we always allow them to in
some kind of neighborhood
so the neighborhood you can use
different loan defined by Ada which is
the zero one number times mu K okay so
we don't need to compute the exact
same alert Center basically
exactly Central pass point
we allow some
some errors
then
well one of the now we're now we reduce
this mu Cube as some gamma gamma is also
between 0 1 we we want a view not
parameter goes to zero right we said
that that's not the goes to Optimal
solution set
so karma control how aggressively reduce
mu okay to the new okay you can think
about this as a new is the it's the next
meal whatever
this is the previous mu
so then you just you want this new you
wanna X as equal to this new mu what do
you do you just apply to the method
still in the feasible region space is
still in the tooth those are anemia the
only non-linear sense is here
but this is more symmetric Newton so
what you can prove
we know this is a newbie class one
how should I reduce Lambda sites that
this new iterate K plus 1K plus 1 K Plus
student
still in the same neighborhood
but here replaced by K plus 1.
so this is the people called homotopic
type of things you keep reduced meal you
always to trace not meal not exactly but
in some neighborhood
so it turned out how how aggressive you
can reduce Lambda
internal this number comes out
so this is exactly what I talk about is
actually one so this would be one minus
square root and this number
it's all from the proof
can you go beyond that okay people
usually say oh maybe we should come
but but if you restricted only one
newton step this is how much you can do
it
so
that that's what you give each time you
reduce view by this factor which is this
number so this number after square root
and step you reduce the view by half by
constant yeah
so that's what's the square root of
incomes in
so that's the same thing is that again
is the balance between how much you how
much you want to duplicate how much you
can compute the new Cent In One Step
because you have the trade
the best 10 out to be square rooted
so that's this number comes
well
unfortunately if you give this algorithm
always reduce gamma
by this one so this is a fixed
geometrical convergence rate
you prove the square root and you need
the square root n step
your algorithm will perform schedule and
step in order to reduce build by a by
half
a lot of people say that's not adaptive
enough it's not practical
if I implement this algorithm according
to this fashion always reduced it's like
without you know now people saying it's
like a parameter a step size or whatever
if you fix that step size nobody can get
efficient practical algorithms
okay so what people do is can weigh more
adaptive
not the algorithm itself
to choose the step size
okay
so one idea choose this step size
is so-called
adapted for password so this has to be
implemented you know there are the
theoretical work in the misunderstood
what I'm just say basic idea
we Define a two neighborhood
so one neighborhood is over that
neighborhood
okay
then we Define another neighborhood
slightly large
at any given point we call a point shoot
in a large neighborhood
then we'll apply another Newton step
always come back in the smaller
neighborhood
the length
how much you reduce mule is completely
decided by how smooth the central part
it is
if their pass is almost like a single
line
with this approach
you shoot to Optimal solution
very fast
so every step contains two steps I'm
just giving you you know Asia sometimes
how to take the theoretical algorithm
into a practical efficient
otherwise we just cannot compete with
those AI people you know they always
tune the primary care and you know doing
something that they automatically to
make the argument adaptive whatever
so uh
anyway that's not reality right now we
have to computer with those guys you
know so uh anyway so this is one way to
to to to to make this argument this
eventually install everybody implemented
in practice
is even more sophisticated yeah
that's a great great question so with
with the finances right
so you define one Ada is 0.9 another
smaller than is 0.5 let's say okay not
from from 0.5 point line make a huge
difference okay so you can shoot all the
way from point line neighborhood because
the Ada is bigger typically we actually
have some parameter choose beta it's
like one neighborhood is the beta
another neighborhood is two beta
beta is something strictly between 0 and
a half
they still keep you in the interior
I don't want to do tremendous help to
improve the okay because in the second
part I'm going to talk about the
coverage of the central parts
the worst case
square root of n
in the good case maybe log n in even
better case even constant so virtually
right now interior Point algorithm solve
these problems
empirically
the number step is not a square length
it's more like a login
maybe that's that that's what the most
they need a program is the coverage I'm
going to talk about anymore
you know called this this past following
algorithms all depend on how smooth
of the central Parts it is yes
yes that's the excellent practice
actually you can prove on the Canadian
care of those kind of things that they
do need to script
oh
oh and more precisely
was this adaptive average
and right now we did we have a one-stat
analysis we know
uh maybe not a square root n is n
one over three
it's not uh
it's not hard to describe it was just
say just say if you follow this Central
paths following algorithm we can
construct the lp from one point decrease
this by
a new point you need that it's a
convergence rate cannot be one over
um
without netting step Newton stepper can
only reduce yeah can come back
so this is a lower bound
so I I don't know I I recently saw an
archival paper they use different
representation of central Parts
arguments
there's still like Central paths for
represented by some square root I don't
know I only see the paper he pulled he
have a complexity Square will end become
a law again
I saw that that's impossible
because we have a at least a cubicle
room
I don't know yeah somebody from an idea
a couple weeks ago
between the program state where we know
already that
equal and
oh
at least some special class yes yes yes
yes yes there was some kind of a class
is later on I'm going to talk about the
condition number
LP those condition numbers dictate how
hard it is
that's all right
amazing work basically organize what's
the courage of the central task it's all
characters
to to coverage I'm going to Define
what's the coverage
you can imagine you know if you have a
past relatively smooth
you can still within sleeper food you
can travel very far without the escape
room without
jump from the neighborhood
this is a piece one second
but however if the code is really cool
um
you cannot speak too much
yeah yeah it's an ordinary programming
is governed all this in two point
arguments
so you can you can think about this
you can say about this past following
your algorithms what do you do
yeah I think this is adaptive algorithm
what do they do is
they just uh
you know doesn't matter you it's all use
piecewise linear right
so give you a curve as you break a curve
how much how many sacraments of
piecewise segment you can move from one
point to another point
uh this is so I'm going to talk about
people developed this is called the
sequential piecewise line segment the
complexity improves the iteration of
India and these social with how much how
much nine piecewise nine curve can
approximate arbitrary algebraic curve
yes so just to follow up on special
instruction I can't comment on the login
thing yes uh
I don't know about that but but um just
to clarify so that the condition number
measures are they are there ones that
govern like whether it's like root end
or n to the one-third as opposed to
governing how many Beyond Ruden you need
to get an exact answer
yeah so is there any I I guess
or even just like having
them exactly it's really depends on how
many layers
so if you take a look at media program
new programs
uh so it was so uncommentation number
which governs the square number is the
largest one minimized at any given View
Central pass point
where I have a x bill right
what's the largest one it would be nice
if you know when you have the xmu
you have this x bill
sum goes to zero
some goes to analytical
to some number which is
if the range of this value all stayed
together
this range this this
like a dual side they all also have same
magnitude close to zero
okay it's together
that's the government
not a racial actually you can prove
actually you you don't need Square brain
thank you yeah this is one way to to do
this is one way to define so the hardest
part including commitment even for
Simplex mass of actually uh for my
syntax must apply to the to to the mdp
program again this number is it's like
you don't want to have some one variable
so you have this kind of a crazy layers
or whatever things create differences
so anyway so this is uh I'm just uh yeah
of course there was another way what the
people also develop because the in the
original Karma Casa offerings called the
potential function why don't we directly
minimize those volumes you know and then
we're to create some ratio which is the
learning of protosol this is the product
of an inner objective combined together
can we have argument minimize those
things people people want the one
without yeah well one criticize past the
following is because they they don't
have it's very hard to manage their
adaptivities okay but however if you
have a single function and minimize
each reduction and minimize more the
better of the algorithms
so that's what you know then you can
introduce the step size parameter and
all those kind of things you don't have
to follow very sophisticated rules how
to design your argument just minimize
the single functions you know that's
that's what happens in in AI training
it's just construct a single question
minimize it okay I don't care how you
minimize it it's just you know more so
anyway I I just wanted to see the
question is you can still solve the same
system equation but here you can adapt
the stats this step size does not
governed by The Neighborhood you can go
beyond the neighborhood as not as the
level side is still in decreasing so
this potentially gives you an even
larger size so I'm running time so I
just move very fast okay so uh what yeah
it's just it's just the curriculated
this so-called potential functions and
then you can minimize this is a row row
is the n plus square root of the N
another nice thing about this once you
have a single question you can also do
alternating so this is so-called
potential function so this is a primal
variable this is the two variables you
have a joint logarithmic so it's like a
running
you can represent this by Duality Gap
will become a linear function so one
method is fix the Y as you minimize this
X
that's what's the original kamaka's
potential function if you assume you
already know what's the optimal value
whether you can use the alternating
strategy so you minimize fix the Y fixed
value only make my only minimize X until
you cannot reduce any more then you can
prove now is 10 for y to make a movement
for you to make a move so it's like a
primal go go as fast you can go
if you cannot go you can prove then is
reduce 10 you can make substantially
Improvement okay so this is a
alternating method very popular in
machine Learning Community because they
don't want to move everything together
they want divides them conquer and move
these files and fix this
okay so this strategy which is also
implementable so this is actually first
approve the same complexity and also
this alternating strategy was also
forced extended to solve sdp
I don't know how many people heard about
the sdp which is also very
point so far
what's the popular method is in table
for LP
you cannot say interior point of Master
dominate Simplex still
very very popular
yeah you can then another way is you can
do
uh since since I have a single single
function to minimize subject to linear
constraints
you don't have to use Newton method you
can use the first order method
as also nowadays very popular
okay
I don't know how to develop a first
order massive or path following because
password is very algebraic you have to
satisfy those system equations you have
to solve systems mineralize it it
becomes so system equation but if you
have a single function minimize it
the more you minimize
the more converges faster of your
algorithm and if you say oh new the
message is too expensive I can use a
first order method okay so uh I just
give you an idea
a very popular approach for the people
developer real LP solver
okay uh they actually use the first
order method
as a start with
still give you a better Central parts or
for the initial point
then the shift to Second over the method
okay so to speed up typically uh first
yeah for depending on what's the
accuracy for high accuracy first order
message basically broke down whatever
because they have this one over Epsilon
or something dependency whatever
but the second word about the immune
from high Epsilon but are still faster
but if you use this first map give you a
few few steps give them a very good
initial point of the second board to
start with
you you basically can read those bad
Central pass points and then you've got
usually you convergence very fast so
that's another Advantage okay
uh yeah I also just wanted to know I
don't know how many people heard about
the
complexity problems
Nina complementation is defined by any
Matrix Square Matrix and MX plus Q X
great zero s group equal to zero and
then the complementary
so this occurred in many many
equilibrium problems I just want to know
this potential reduction algorithm of
course if this is m is a secure
symmetric that's the lp
if the m is a magic kind of model Point
what's the model tongue means this for
any difference m is critical zero
basically M plus M transfer is symmetric
positive semi-definition then this
basically become a convex QP
okay so so this is all your money so
this is what the
extent to this but however there were
some other Matrix which happened in some
equilibrium analysis you can use this
which depends on so-called condition
number for example you can generate a
point over here depending on some kind
of condition it's called Lambda Lambda
is the least again value of this could
be negative okay however it's also
dependent on what's so-called this gamma
which is called the code Matrix
condition number for p Matrix anyway
this problem is not convex but you can
still be able to solve it
depending on condition number okay also
you can create some apps among stuff
okay so anyway so initial addition you
can kill many people worry about the
Innovation you can construct the timer
do whatever to do it
so yes so this is uh yeah you you can
you can you can develop so you don't
need to worry about that
what does the initial phase of Origins
have an interior or not okay from the
inner program is everything
so so that's the current you know for
linear programming
but
what's the final
are we need to resolve another big
question when the lp have a strong
polynomial or not
what it means 20 polynomial
converges is exact convergence
the number of steps or number iterations
a number of operation arithmet
Corporation
only dependent on dimension of
polynomial intervention
okay so I'm going to keep maybe would
take some break on that part only need
a half hour to finish
because it's more open questions not
answers so give to you guys
so we take a break okay
thank you
any questions before the break
um
Value method
yeah so the question is relate to
current commercial solver for media
programming which which method they use
the interior Point method which one is
implemented oh so why Implement is
pretty much predict correct follow that
adaptive list but more practical use
sound German roaches paper
then
they also have a lot of a team up
how to scale the things
okay how do they also have a
precondition on those kind of things
because in Japan eventually depends on
some conditional a matrix as I said if
you can scale The Matrix everybody those
positive variables all goes together you
know stay very close
all of a tricky things so I would say
that right now the interior point of
commercial solver is not the theoretical
algorithm we present over here
which is add a lot of tricks to do those
but all those preconditional those
tricks
come from some kind of a theoretical
indications
I think that's the difference from the
AI training and you know those Engineers
just can just add how I can just train
something well
I just enjoy experimental science but
yes you need a lot of tricks okay how to
solve systemic equations all these kinds
in terms of interior performance and
Simplex method right now no dominance
some problems Simplex fast sometimes but
for sides getting bigger in here but you
get faster
now because the Simplex method is really
needed to solve integer linear program
they really want to compute the
correlation
but even now people if you to start with
they start with the entire point because
too big
yes okay so yeah for your talk uh I just
want to ask an obvious question that
probably everyone wants to know the
answer to so in prep as you said like in
practice interior Point methods work
extremely well so do on the other hand
we have these very pathologic instances
like the clementic yes where provably it
requires large number of iterations uh
I'm curious what's your intuition about
this thing is it maybe that for all
reasonable instances or all reasonable
linear programming instances that we can
represent using where we can write the
numbers using you know logarithmically
many bits maybe the maybe the central
path is you know is short enough it's
not so curvy that actually we can prove
something that interior Point method is
actually provably must converge faster
than routine iterations yes yes I think
that's the that's yeah Aaron property
also can answer but what are we missing
because like you know like in sparse
instances we still learn how to prove
anything like that in the general case
yeah so I think it's very hard to
identify which ones they use the lp
which means how the lp at the very
beginning but but one one representing
is the size of data it's like L right
another is some condition number but
some of those conditions have even
computer them is there so it's very hard
to
I don't know I think that's a great
question to lead into some discussions
over the break I guess we're a bit over
yeah so actually the second part is
under some of your questions
so
is there a smooth analysis type yeah
we're going to take a break thank you
very much okay so thank you very much
um So based on the timing that you said
if this sounds good to you let's take a
break now until 3 45 I want to make sure
everyone properly has their coffee on
this Friday
um and then we'll come back then they'll
leave 45 minutes for the final session
does that sound good to you all right
let's do that so see you all then thank
you
that's not a smart question